[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous retrouver dans
le 7-8 loisirs toutes vos idées sorties
dans le département on commence tout de
suite avec le sommaire de ce numéro
une journée de fête de la maison elsa
triolet aragon animations et ateliers
avec des artistes mais aussi des
conseils jardinage ça se passera
dimanche de juillet à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines le point sur
ces festivités avec tyr colas et de la
maison triolet aragon un cabaret en
hommage à l'oeuvre de l'auteur allemand
bertolt brecht heures un spectacle
musical qui regroupe une centaine
d'artistes c'est à découvrir ce week end
dans le parc du château de plaisir
alliés de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
glissez vous dans la peau d'un gymnaste
de dimanche de juillet un rendez vous
pour découvrir la discipline et ses
différentes pratiques mélanie poker nous
en dira plus dans notre rendez-vous
junior et si vous célébriez la fête
nationale en compagnie des pompiers à
montigny-le-bretonneux la première
édition du bal des pompiers aura lieu le
14 juillet à leurs casernes
un cours de zumba une tombola des fous 3
qui est des dit
vous attendent dès 19h30 jusqu'à 3
heures du matin une soirée à ne pas
manquer on écoute le sergent sébastien
davoust il était au micro de medinat
correia et charline hurel
traditionnellement en fait les pompiers
organisé un bal tous les ans sur le 14
juillet qui était un peu fédérateur qui
permettait aux gens de se retrouver pour
pouvoir danser ensemble pour partager
des moments conviviaux le ballon tennis
et
le 14 juillet à 19h30 voilà on vous
attend nombreux
il y aura plein d'animations l'entrée
est à 10 euros
il ya des préventes actuellement sur
facebook liée avec weezevent à 8 euros
sachant que l'entrée comprend aussi une
boisson
une programmation éclectique et
alternatives ce samedi 1er juillet à
voisins le bretonneux pour son premier
festival de la tour mais les boîtes
une dizaine de groupes vont se produire
sur scène dès 15 heures des concerts des
performances en village associatif et
des animations à retrouver à la salle de
la tour pour se mettre en appétit je
vous propose d'écouter un extrait d'une
des formations présentes
il s'agit du groupe de 36 quai des lic
hilight tribe et de son titre esperanza
un mélange d'instruments ethnique avec
un son résolument moderne
écoutez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une journée bucolique et poétique à la
maison elsa triolet aragon à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines vous êtes
attendus ce dimanche de juillet pour une
après midi animé en présence d'artistes
de comédiens et de jardiniers pierre
colas de la maison triolet aragon est
avec nous pour nous parler du programme
bonjour pierre colas jo alors dites-nous
qu'est ce qui nous attend dimanche
qu'est ce que vous avez prévu
eh bien on blues absolument nous élisons
donc dans le parc de louis aragon et
elsa triolet
il avait un but magnifique propriété
donc à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines est au
bout quand arrivent les beaux jours on a
envie de d'accueillir des compagnies des
associations pour célébrer avec nous le
retour du jardin son réveil
et justement dimanche vous pourrez
rencontrer donc trois compagnies d'arts
de rue des des chanteurs des musiciens
et des ateliers proposés par des
associations locales
alors justement qu'est ce qu'il y aura
comme atelier comme atelier il y aura du
dessin notamment ce genre de choses on
aura du dessin qui est proposé par
l'association art passion ouverte
croquer le paysage on aura aussi de la
lecture avec la médiathèque et à
saint-arnoult qui proposera donc aux
ateliers pour tous les âges et aussi
même des ateliers lutherie puisque vous
fabriquer aussi des instruments de
musique se fruits et légumes ou encore
des ateliers de land art pour explorer
gestion plus le parquet laissait
quelques fois des oeuvres d'art éphémère
dans sur la propriété
après on l'a dit 4 les animations dont
vous avez parlé des compagnons ça des
compagnies d'arts de rue du manège
poétique ça veut dire ça alors qu'est ce
que c'est la neige politique c'est assez
marrant c'est un manège à bras ont donc
on le fait tourner
à la force de nos bras s'était fabriqué
par la compagnie de la voûte et c'est un
tour du monde 15 arrêts pour aux plus
jeunes enfants accompagnée de son
accordéon et donc il faudra plusieurs
heures pendant le tout l'après midi
alors qui sont ces compagnies on aura
aussi les souffleurs un commando
poétique qui fait des apparitions
disparitions dans le parc
il vient chuchoter des vers de poésie
dans le creux de l'oreille aussi évolué
plaît à certains musiciens qui sait
fabriquer des instruments de musique
avec donc des carottes et des ou des who
déco ou les courgettes ou d'autres
fruits ans comme les légumes et donc lui
il viendra à la fois vous apprendre à le
faire et aussi organiser son concert à
la fin du à la fin de l'après midi
et puis ça marquera aussi la fin de la
résidence de dives rousseau à la mjc de
de rambouillet elle est là usine à
chapeaux il y aura donc des sessions de
jazz tout l'après-midi aussi donc
donc tous après midi à retrouver du
justement de la musique beaucoup de
musique mais aussi du jardin le nom de
l'animation c'est aussi jardins en fête
dont tu auras des jardiniers c'est aussi
l'occasion de demander des conseils pour
s'occuper de ses fleurs de ces plantes
pendant l'été
absolument c'est le thème etc c'est
aussi l'occasion de venir récupérer des
graines de faire des échanges recevoir
des conseils aussi avec les jardiniers
de france qui seront là et qui vous
donneront aussi les bonnes astuces pour
cet été comment vous est venue l'idée de
créer ce
cette animation s'était déjà deux
événements existants indépendamment que
vous avez choisi de réunir en fait c'est
ça l'idée oui on avait déjà depuis très
longtemps et compagnies d'arts de rue
qui venaient ici parce que c'est notre
ambition et si la maison triolet aragon
a proposé la poésie sous toutes ses
formes
on cherche de nouvelles formes et les
compagnies d'arts de rue étaient
accueillis dans poésie bissonnier
répandant prendre près de dix ans et on
avait aussi un festival des jardins
parole aux jardiniers là justement les
deux ont fusionné cette année dont
jardins en fête
et justement on crée des synergies aussi
en faisant se rencontrer l'association
locale en faisant les rencontrer aussi
les artistes donc à la fois ces deux
rencontres donc les jardiniers des
musiciens des poètes à cet endroit là
réunir deux univers complètement en fait
même plus que deux univers et un dernier
mot justement pour l'été vous êtes
également ouvert on peut venir visiter
la maison un triolet aragon
indépendamment de cet événement qui se
passe dimanche
oui on retrouvera toujours les visites
de la maison avec l'exposition
temporaire du moment le sur le peintre
benjamin ce parc est à cette occasion on
proposera aussi un atelier de bande
dessinée les mercredis des vacances pour
les enfants de 4 à 12 ans donc ils
pourront s'initier aussi à cela en même
temps qu'ils découvriront l'exposition
aux animations en tout cas à ne pas
manquer que ce soit dimanche comme pour
tout l'été merci beaucoup de cas pire
que la est revenu sur notre plateau pour
nous parler de ces différents événements
et n'oubliez pas la maison elsa triolet
aragon vous accueille ce dimanche de
juillet pour une après midi festive et
n'hésitez pas à faire un tour sur leur
site internet pour retrouver l'ensemble
du programme
merci beaucoup pierre colas un cabaret
inspiré de l'oeuvre de l'écrivain
bertold brecht c'est à découvrir à
plaisir tout le week end à comédiens
musiciens chanteurs et danseurs une
centaine d'artistes se produira en plein
air dans le parc du château
nous avons suivi les répétitions de
théâtre imaginez nicolas landry il fit
afin bout le marié y aller d'une demi
bouteille d'eau de cologne sauter avatar
day tout le monde
l'univers du dramaturge bertolt brecht
prend ses appartements à plaisir sous la
direction du metteur en scène olivier
besson un spectacle musical un cabaret
déjanté qui réunit plusieurs des grands
textes de l'auteur allemand brèche c'est
vraiment un auteur politique et donc les
thématiques on aborde c'est le rapport
amoureux mais au travers de la question
de l'argent de la question du pouvoir
ces scellés rapport de la famille et de
la dire les rapports bourgeois de la
famille
c'est la question de la guerre du
rapport à la guerre c'est l'exploitation
et c'est beaucoup évidemment puisque
c'est le thème fondamental de brecht
c'est l'exploitation de l'homme par
l'homme
plusieurs scènes articulée autour d'un
fil conducteur grandeur et décadence de
la ville de mahagonny un opéra de
bertold brecht qui raconte la naissance
d'une ville imaginaire
fondée par trois criminels en amérique
c'est quand même un des plus grands
auteurs du 20e siècle et c'est tout le
temps un travail un plaisir pour les
acteurs de serpents chez cic replonger
c'est quelqu'un qui interroge le monde
le rapport au monde la justice et en
même temps c'est du plaisir c'est un
cabaret c'est un signe de l'amusement
sait jamais et c'est didactique ne sait
jamais en mieux comédiens et musiciens
amateurs et professionnels se produiront
ensemble un théâtre à ciel ouvert dans
le parc du château de plaisir du veau à
la santé 2 et 2 être jeune et noble qui
aujourd'hui vont appartenir l'un à
l'autre
comme chaque semaine mélanie poker nous
a rejoints en plateau et aujourd'hui
vous nous proposez de faire de la
gymnastique
c'est à l'espace événementiel de l'est
de loisirs de 50 en une que ça va se
passer le comité départemental des
yvelines de gymnastique vous ai donné un
rendez vous le 2 juillet toute une
journée dans la peau d'un gymnaste
l'occasion de peut-être découvrir votre
future activité extrascolaire c'est une
c'est une animation
à faire la promotion de la gymnastique
dans le cadre d'un grand événement
international qui sait son retour sur
paris au mois de septembre
c'est pour les curieux toute personne
qui a envie de découvrir la gymnastique
alors soit pour regarder soi pour
pratiques et donc ça cesse et destiné
également aux plus jeunes aux enfants
notamment mais aussi aux adolescents
alors un petit souci technique et on a
bien pu entendre un dominique semedo
s'exprimer
la gymnastique ça regroupe un grand
nombre de disciplines alors qu'est ce
qu'on va pouvoir tester ce week end
alors la première découverte proposée
qu'à me fait du trampoline avec un mini
trampoline mais aussi un grand il y aura
aussi une piste de tumbling discipline
originaires des etats unis où il faut
enchaîner des acrobaties sur une piste
de 25 mètres et toutes les activités
s'adressent aux filles comme aux garçons
et plusieurs petites grèce seront aussi
installés alors ce sera l'occasion de
tester les barres parallèles ou encore
la poutre l'encadrement sera fait par
les membres du comité départemental
mais la journée sera rythmée par la
présence d'athlètes qui répondront à
toutes les questions que vous pouvez
vous poser alors l'animation est
comprise dans le prix de l'entrée de
l'île de loisirs et si jamais vous avez
un coup de coeur pour la gymnastique
pourquoi ne pas assister aux
internationaux de france entend parler à
dominique semedo ils ont eu lieu à paris
en septembre prochain
merci beaucoup mélanie nous avoir parlé
de ce rendez vous on passe maintenant à
notre agenda
[Musique]
à maurepas ce samedi c'est une journée
entièrement consacrée au vélo balade
dans la ville parcours de bmx karting et
atelier de gravure de vélo il y aura
même un grand run and bike à 17 heures
une journée sportive à ne pas manquer on
continue dans le sport mais avec une
petite balle blanche cette fois 150
joueurs de golf s'affrontent pour la
nouvelle édition de l'open de france
vous avez jusqu'à dimanche pour assister
à cette compétition hors normes au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est la fin de cette étude choisir je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivis je
vous souhaite un excellent week end et
je vous dis à pendre des prochains
oui
où